we just didn't give ourselves a chance
an opportunity to take some shots at the
end zone obviously i had a little chance
at the last one i just tried to give my
guys a shot um we came short
back on that throw there at the end did
it kind of flip out of your hands did
you have a good grip on it i mean
obviously it wasn't as nice of a spiral
as i wanted to i'm pretty sure it
slipped a little bit didn't have my feet
underneath me obviously um but wish i
could have maybe bought a couple more
seconds but once again i got to go back
and check out the film maybe i could
have set my feet uh who knows who knows
right now i've got to go look at it
zac prescott talking about the last
offensive play from dallas 3831 laws to
seattle on sunday we broke that game
down yesterday carefully chris we didn't
put a lot of focus on the final play but
it was an example of incredible
escapability yeah by dak prescott
because if he falls if he stumbles and
he did stumble yeah that knee hits the
ground game's over right you've got 11
seconds at the moment his knee would
have hit you've got all your receivers
in the end zone you're not getting all
those guys back lined up and another
play called snapped by that and even if
you do it's going to be keystone cops
right so
what do you do
after you have twisted and turned and
almost fallen down and then re-gather
yourself what he did was he fired the
ball into the end zone and got
intercepted right right now chris before
we
go down this jerry jones diddy or didn't
he criticize dak rabbit hold
i i think from the benefit of
hindsight
and tuesday wednesday thursday
quarterbacking we can say i can say
dak had enough time to run out of bounds
and get one more play he could have
bought a few more seconds before he
threw the ball he could have taken
another click or two while he ran
forward toward the line of scrimmage to
see whether or not someone really was
open because no one was open he threw
the ball into a cluster of bodies and it
was intercepted but you know that's part
of the challenge and that's one of the
skills of extending a play you have to
also be able to refocus and reorient
yourself on what's going on down the
field once you have escaped a sack and
you're moving laterally after you have
almost like with a play-action pass when
you turn your back to the field you have
to refocus on everything that's
happening and figure out who's open and
who is well exactly right you know and
he's trying to throw the ball to the
back of the end zone and you'll see here
on the first the first frame that we're
showing like okay you don't see the
intended receiver he's trying to throw
to at this moment it's really noah brown
which kristen if you go to the next
picture picture you'll see there he is
and yeah doc prescott did not flush the
throw right it wasn't pure it probably
didn't come out of his hand with all the
pop and everything uh that you know the
spiral to control everything he needed
to make the throw perfect first off it's
a very tough situation you could see
there the seahawks know he's throwing it
in the end zone there's four guys there
already they're ready and there's a
fifth just outside the screen to get
into the play as well so yeah could doc
prescott maybe have just thrown he could
have thrown it away could he ran out of
bounds and lost a few yards yeah maybe
you know but at the same time like
he dropped back to pass it's a three-man
rush he's got five on three and
immediately he has pressure so the
cowboys offensive line even though they
had two more people couldn't block the
other three guys they he bust through so
now he's in frenzy mode too right mike
try to put yourself in his shoes where
okay you're in frenzy mode you know oh
no i might go down holy crap i stayed up
and now you're going wait i don't know
how much time's on the clock and how
close of these guys that are right next
to me right now really you know after
i've regained my balance and everything
like that to where you probably are
gonna rush everything a little bit
because you're worried about wait am i
going to even be able to get this ball
off in time am i going to get sacked and
i'm sure he rushed it a little bit and
it didn't i got any solution yeah easy
solution right throw it away throw it
away
don't throw it to the end zone throw it
out of bounds pass the line of scrimmage
you're outside the pocket he's not
intentional i know i said that i said
that already i said he could have ran
out of bounds he could have thrown it
away right but he took one shot he gives
himself another shot to throw it into
the end zone he's going to be throwing
this same type of throw the next play no
matter what i mean seattle knows what's
going down he's gonna end up having to
throw a ball and do a crowd of bodies to
win the football game and hope his guy
comes up with it he just didn't unless
you got a play drawn up remember that
tyree kill play when the chiefs played
the cowboys yeah that's
instead of throwing it to the end zone
now they don't have a tyre kill it helps
have a tyre kill they got a cd lamb they
could draw something up well they could
have thrown it to the end all right but
don't if yes they didn't do that that's
not on dak prescott then if somebody
should have if we told him another play
and figure that out but that's not dak
prescott's fault here's the point we're
just setting the table yeah because
there was
a comment yesterday from jerry jones
and when i saw the words because there
was a buzz yesterday that he had
compared dak in a not so favorable way
to quarterbacks like patrick mahomes
russell wilson and tony romo i saw the
words and i thought he's really not
comparing them in an unfavorable way
he's comparing them in a favorable way
because they all have mobility to extend
place but then yesterday on pftpm for
the first time i actually heard right
what jerry jones said you get to hear it
now and have an open mind as you listen
to jerry jones the mellifluous tones of
cowboys owner jerry jones
ask yourself
is he
criticizing dak or is he lumping him in
in a positive way with these other
quarterbacks here it is
and obviously with their quarterback
who's
i think at the highest
level right now
because of his frankly as
much as just his natural ability to make
plays his mobility and this guy is very
quick and elusive and can get in and out
of situations with his feet and by time
the quarterback we played sunday is of
that kind of nature has great ability to
get in and out
and then
make the play that played dak made at
the end of the game that got intercepted
well uh
the result of dax ability that let him
get that ball off was uh really great
and outstanding well these guys have
that ability a lot they are very quick
footed
and they're very they have the unique
ability to possibly take their eyes uh
away from the field for a minute and
then immediately focus back
and see
romo had that
and so they could turn his back on it
and turn around and hand eye and get it
done quick
and so those are things that show up and
that's what's showing up with these guys
they're buying time with their feet for
buying time with their instincts and
their feet
see when i first saw the words chris my
reaction was that jerry jones is saying
patrick mahomes that was the first
quarterback he was talking about russell
wilson tony romo dak prescott all have
the ability to buy time with their feet
something we've been talking about
repeatedly in recent weeks because
that's the dividing line between the
good quarterbacks and the great
quarterbacks good quarterback can run
the play that's called but when it goes
to crap you got to do something but the
reference to the interception
and the reference to the ability of
these other guys to focus
after they've turned their back on the
defense
that's where that little bit of
my guy can't do it like mahomes wilson
and romo could because he threw the
interception he didn't get refocused he
fired the ball into a cluster of bodies
and the ball got picked off
uh it's not refocusing at all it's just
getting rid of the football before you
get splattered and
and when i hear it when i see the words
i think no criticism when i hear the
words yeah there's just something there
that makes me think he wishes his guy
who's here
was just a little bit higher when it
comes to the ability to elude and then
to make good decisions after you've
managed to elude those who are chasing
yeah i i'm listen
i'm with you all the way like when you
read it it is a little different than
when you hear it and i don't like when i
hear it i don't think he's
he's trying to like take a shot at dak
prescott or anything like that i mean
first he's complimenting him about how
what of a great job he was to stay up on
that play and do that but then he kind
of says like he doesn't have that a
natural elusive ability
like the rest of those other guys do who
can do it on a play-by-play basis and
kind of goes there so yeah i mean it is
a little bit of a you know under the
table shot there a little bit now i mean
the big thing is that's that not dak
prescott's game you know he moves well
i mean he he runs well i mean he they
they they quarterback design runs read
option he runs over people for
touchdowns at the two yard line you know
but is he a a scrambler and a dancer in
the pocket like russell wilson mahomes
rogers desean watson even josh allen at
this point
no he's not that's not the type of
player he is it's never been about what
he is now with people around him and
breaking tackles and things like that
he's amazing but he's comparing him
right now and dak prescott is a
franchise quarterback but to compare him
to russell and mahomes like
you know again let's just be realistic
here those guys are off the charts
they're first ballot hall of famers
right now like right now i mean patrick
mahomes is like one of those guys if he
played two more years we'd be like let's
induct him into the hall of fame that's
a good enough career for me i've never
saw anybody do that and russell wilson's
doing the same type of crap so yeah i
don't think dak prescott is as good as
russell wilson or homes or any of those
guys i don't but he's really damn
awesome and damn did he make a lot of
good throws in that football game that's
just not part of what he does but either
way you put the people around him and
everything like that he can win and he
can bring you to a super bowl he can but
they got other issues on that team
rather than dak prescott's scrambling
ability and not being like russell
wilson
there's just a wistful quality to the
way that jerry jones was talking about
patrick holmes and russell wilson and
romo he just jammed romo into the
conversation
was trending yesterday but the point is
the point is this is all being uttered
at a time when they're paying back 31.4
million this year he's due to make
37.68 million next year if they tag him
again he's wanted that long-term deal
that's going to get more and more
expensive as time goes by because the
cowboys haven't paid him and i think
it's indicative of
the thing that has stopped the cowboys
from caving that if they had mahomes or
wilson they would just write the check
but there's something that's holding
them back from making the all-in
commitment to dak prescott and look i'm
not suggesting that there was anything
deliberate or it was a signal or it was
a message of what's going to happen next
year but
there was a quality in that that sound
that was coming from jerry jones
that makes me think
his quarterback situation isn't really
where he wants it to be until he's got
one of those guys you're not going to
get one of those guys that's just not
going to happen no because even
first of all
you know neither of those guys we knew
before the draft they were going to be
who they were pat from homes went 10th
overall russell wilson was the third
round pick you you just can't wave a
wand and get one of these guys your
sometimes you gotta do the best you can
with who you have that's right to your
point i mean they got tony romo they
probably didn't expect him to be like
that you know what
tony robbins drafted undrafted right so
yeah you're right and he's plenty
elusive he makes plenty of plays off
schedule you know again we're talking
about like all-time wheeler and dealers
and mahomes and wilson and rogers and
those type of guys i mean they're like
as slick as the with the ball as anybody
you've ever seen i mean they're show men
they're craftsman that way yeah dak
prescott's a little bit more of your
traditional like i'm going to stand in
there and i'm big and strong and i'm
going to fire this ball and if i have to
run i can run it's going to be straight
away running he's not going to dance
around and make people miss and then
look down field and do that no that's
that's just not his game you can't have
it all you know you can't and yeah
unfortunately
uh
prescott does not have that ability like
those guys do but damn it's still a lot
of really good ability and you watch
that game back i mean there was a number
of high level throws that are not just
easy you go whoa he put that ball on the
money down the field aggressively and
does some things that you know make your
jaw drop a little every now and then
and jerry it could be worse instead of
dak prescott your choices for a short
week game against the new york jets
could be jeff driscoll blake bortles oh
man a guy with the last name of ripon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports